[Musique]
le premier tour se dissout
qui est ininterrompu parce que dans un autre pays
je ne vois pas le chef
il y a un chef, il y a une donnée, il y a une danseuse du ventre
remis au chef
[Musique]
Nous sommes Tayyip Erdogan depuis 2003.
Nous le soutenons depuis que c'est arrivé.
Par exemple, il a apporté de nombreux changements.
dans le domaine de la technologie
dans le domaine scientifique
les conditions de vie des gens
très efficace pour faciliter
je crois que tu l'as fait
[Musique]
franchement, nous attirons le plus les jeunes.
chef du parti de la ville natale
Muharrem Ince en ce moment nous sommes à lui
Disons qu'on est fans alors franchement
ça va trop changer les idées
Je ne pense pas que la structure de la tête de la personne
le chemin qu'il a pris est clair
Il est clair que cela ne changera guère
franchement je ne pense pas
Que ce soit la langue d'Antep pour que les gens
Qu'ils disent ce qui a été fait, je jure Fruit
L'arbre qui donne est lapidé Oublie-le.
ne te fatigue pas
[Musique]